hello everyone I hope they are good
today is Friday and that means the
trading week is about to finish and what
a shame right because this trading week
has been amazing we've got loads of
volatility and me as a day trader I'm
probably most of you will love it
because volatility means opportunities
for us I mean this week look at check
this out please Monday
a four percent drop then a six percent
pump a retreat of a three percent
another Spike up of four percent a
retreat of two percent I mean what else
can you ask for and these weeks are
usually quite difficult to predict when
there is so much volatility so many news
announcements
and you don't really know what the
results are gonna be but you have to
also play with the chart because it's
true that sometimes the chart can
anticipate what the news are gonna say
Okay especially in a in a bull market I
would say now in a bad Market I think
it's harder because
at this this bear Market is purely
driven by data so
um it's even harder to make predictions
so when I make a plan for the week and
it comes pretty close to reality check
this out that was a very good time in
that point in the New York session
okay but of course it's not perfect
because this could have been lower okay
something like this
but again
when you get quite close to reality and
if you go across to reality and it gives
you enough conviction to put your money
in the trades
then you know it's all good so
personally I'm I'm very happy with uh
this training week I've also gone
through uh the the profits that I made
this week and it's been one of the best
weeks I've had in the whole year it's
not it hasn't been the best one but top
three top five yes so I'm very happy for
that
and I also want to say thank you for all
of you that have been watching the
videos every day reading the tweets
every day but I know that you know it's
many of you so I hope that the content
could help you this week that you've
made some money that you also avoided
losing money that's also uh the most
important part so uh if that's the case
thank you so much
um I would appreciate if you tell me if
you had a good or about trading week
that's out of curiosity but anyway I
wanna tell you a bit now of I would say
kind of like um
autocritic like I'm gonna uh you know
try to this is good for for me too I'm
gonna try to see the good things and the
bad things that I've done this week and
how I could have improved my results so
first of all
I started with a long this week okay and
that was around this one here around 25
100 and that was basically because we
had here a strong support
okay
that's so you can see all the books to
the downside but then on Monday which is
usually a false move day then you see
the drop and consolidation again backup
of support so that was telling me you
know creepy mobile it's time to long
this Market because that's probably
Monday's first moved we are
consolidating above support So price is
likely to you know to spike up and start
to recover some imbalances like for
example this one
all right
Asia did the job and I remember that I
closed these Longs from here I close
them in this candle right at the start
of the London session I mean this is
still a very good exit because it's a
one thousand dollars move but it's true
that could have been like one thousand
almost 500 last move if I would have
closed it here
so again maybe I closed it too early
now in hand side table still profit is
profit so I'm gonna I'm not gonna punish
myself so uh then you saw this drop
and I took another long
at the one hour and four hour 50 AMA
test
um again the X could have been better
because I remember that I exit here in
this Zone but could have you know again
maybe overnight but I don't like to hold
it right so it's not really my thing but
it's true that could have closed it here
okay and then the next day I open again
along
because then I was targeting that in the
New Year session on Thursday we would
see this Spike up to hit all this
liquidation so I open along in this Zone
and I closed it quite conservatively
around 26
590 I think it was so around this Zone
and then I opened shorts two shorts at
669 I think it was surround this Zone
and 700 something okay and I want to
tell you what I'm doing with these sorts
first of all I've just took some profits
because we tested 1 out of 50ma that's
usually a place where I like to take
some profits okay now the rest of the
short I'm still holding it because if
you notice we have only five minutes to
close this Candlestick and you know it's
likely that maybe in the next Scandal
women test it as resistance and if
that's the case press and continue going
lower where to well you have the 4 Hour
50ma there waiting for you and that's
gonna be a place where I'm gonna close
the total size of my position okay
because today is Friday and the weekend
is almost here and you guys know that I
don't trip at the weekend because there
is no much volatility price goes up down
it's choppy it's sideways it's pointless
for me to be checking my phone and see
you know how my trade is doing I prefer
to to close the whole trade and then get
back on Monday on the trading
right now if we manage to close some
candlesticks above the one or 50ma then
what this was a personal take profits is
when I become a full take profits okay
because price you know could rent here
over the weekend unable to give some
kind of a spike up because in the 15
minutes time frame it's true that we
have a week here okay now let me remove
today's production cost is done check
this out
that's a week
okay I'm the 50 percent it's around
there
right so you can see how there is also a
week to the upside in the 15 minutes
time frame so that's my logic if we
manage to close
uh counter stick above the one or 50
minutes so if we reclaim that 50 EMA one
hour time frame then my shorts from this
song will be closed and I'll aim to
reopen them again in this Zone
all right that's what I'm
um I'm seeing now if we close
sorry stop clip no change in all these
time frames if we close above the one
hour 50ma then I'll be looking for the
four hour 50ma which is around 26 100 so
around this one
all right underly the target for today
then I'll close my trade and relax only
over the weekend and you know reset to
malcolins make it a bit consumer update
to better ourselves for the next week
and or Monday we start trading again so
that's how I'm trading these okay and I
have it very clear and you probably
notice when I like to do business when
at what time of the day on what days I
like to open trades close rates
and that is very important okay uh you
can call that trade in Psychology uh
trading mindset as you want but that is
very important because you know you
might have the knowledge
you might have the Instinct but if you
don't have the right mindset if you
don't have your ideas clear then you're
gonna make many mistakes okay so this is
how I operate
um in a normal week so that's pretty
much everything regarding to Bitcoin in
the short time frame now let me tell you
what the validation of all this short
idea is well first of all I want to tell
you
even if the 4 or 50ma is what I'll be
taking total profits
okay we still have the problem of this
candle that's an Asian pump and they
usually tend to get retraceable again
price could you know come to the 45th
May good range could give you even a
spike here and then drop
okay that's why I want to close my trade
here if you get there today and I'm not
gonna be holding it to this Zone because
we might see a bounce here all right so
this is the one of your problem and
that's what I think that we should go in
the I don't know I don't know if it's
going to be next week or in a couple of
weeks but this example it's quite
suspicious and it's probably gonna get
to get retrace now the invalidation is
this the daily 50ma okay invalidation
Above This level quite clear for me go
to the Daily time frame let's check this
out guys
first of all you have to understand
where you are
okay let's talk about ranges
that was a range over here
okay
so that was a range
deviation
drop and you drop
into a previous range
which is this one okay
drawing size
and then race low so you could mark this
once or you could even mark them lower
here okay I'm gonna mark them here
because that was the initial drop in the
range okay
by the way
daily 50ma do you say that this purple
line okay
if price manages
to spike up get up of the one daily 50ma
okay testica support or even consolidate
here then that's bullish
um price is gonna go to the range size
of 20 300 or 20 400 okay
so that's the invalidation and if that
happens then when you know when we are
testing our support consider debating
that's where my shot will be close and
that's what I'll be aiming to take Longs
towards the right side so that's in the
midterm what I'm thinking for Bitcoin
okay of course
even if we do that then I do believe
that still the liquidity is to the
downside
in this Zone here okay so even if we
play some kind more of a range like this
I think eventually the the breakdown
for the breakout will be to the downside
right so that's clear to me because in
the weekly time frame we have a couple
of problems here for Bitcoin
because we have first of all the the
weekly 50ma testing assistance it's a 26
814.
and you know we just SL resistance again
yesterday so that's a resistance and you
also have here this liquidity for this
in Valencia are 2100 and of course to me
the key in the chart which is this week
over here and that is basically
the 50 of this week minimum Target 20
700 so the question is
mobile are you expecting twenty thousand
seven hundred to get hit
and the answer is yes as long as we
continue below the weekly 50 main there
is no other way but
to go lower and Target distance
that's what I see in the market all
right short term midterm long term
okay bull market when well the bull
market then is likely to start next
summer 2024. we'll see what happens but
you know according to the forger cycler
I've been explaining this in previous
videos months ago
use release in the half India two to
three months after Harbin if the Harbin
is in a spring
of 2024 then by summer we should have
for Bull Run and that's also maybe by
spring when the ETF gets approved
and we're gonna have more liquidity new
people coming into crypto and that would
boost the bull market so that's what I
think for Bitcoin guys okay now let's go
to High block capital and check what is
going on there the first thing that I
want to check in hablo Capital are the
liquidation levels let's check the belt
okay
12 billion dollars worth of long
liquidations okay this is telling you
that basically look total long
liquidation 606 total requisitions 200
that means that per every one short
position
there are three long positions open so
who is at risk to miss clear the long
positions okay 12 million dollars are a
lot of liquidations check this pack to
the downside many many spikes here okay
25 700 biggest Spike there twenty five
thousand four hundred eighty eight
biggest Spike there 25 200 another spec
of liquidations there so
you know the logic tells me that
this is not a place where I will open
any lungs okay and we've been talking
about the Delta this all this week and
I've been telling you I think it's gonna
get to 10 billions and then that's maybe
we can see a drop to retrace these
spikes and maybe it is still correct so
that's still what I'm gonna be looking
at now liquidations hit map what is
going on in the 70s time frame well with
it or Target okay check out these
liquidation here
and this one I've been telling you you
can Spike you don't hit this liquidity
the Liquidators increase another Spike
you don't have this liquidity the
inquisitions increase and the only thing
that they are doing there is to increase
the Liquidations in that soon so when
price pushes towards that zone like here
then they're gonna hit more liquidations
that they could have done previously
it's all about efficiency and you see
the same thing in the three months time
frame but to the downside check this out
tell me that what is happening in this
zone is not the same are weak but you
don't hit the Zone a spike down but you
don't hit this Zone meanwhile all these
liquidations are increasing and maybe
who knows in a couple of weeks or a
month a month and a half who knows you
see that drop to this Zone and hit all
these liquidations
okay that's what the market works it's
all about liquidity it's all about
taking your money simple as that all
right but anyway so in this time frame
what is the liquidity now well there are
some liquidations appearing at 27 000
that is basically the daily 50ma so that
would be also if you recover the one or
50 May and place where you could put
some limit orders all right and then you
have to the downside more liquidations
are 24 700 25 650 right so the liquidity
I would say right now is more to the
downside and then in the one month time
frame
there are some liquidations appearing
Above This highs okay that's just really
what happens you know usually above
previous size and Below previous lows
there are liquidity so there are some
liquidity I put in a 25 28 500 at the
right size that I've mentioned but for
that you still need to get acceptance
above the daily 50ma otherwise
you're not gonna get there and then
three months time frame you guys know
the story what is still looking at this
Zone to get hit over the next few weeks
six months time frame having 61 for ages
but oh wow
24 300.
all right this one is gonna get hit
sooner or later for sure
something is telling me that the
liquidity is in the midterm to the
downside so that's my reason to no open
sewing lungs okay if you get to the
right in size at 28 000
okay and that's once you get acceptance
above the daily 50ma to get above it and
get test their support so then you can
Spike price up again towards the rain
size that's a place where I would be
looking to open shoeing shorts okay
targeting this lower zone so that's
pretty much everything guys I hope that
this video has been helpful and you've
had a very good trading week
um if so please let me know in the
comments I wanna I wanna hear even if
you tell me look I've made this mistake
with my entry this mistake with my exit
or look after taking this I've only
taken one trade and it's been great I
just want to hear your opinion about how
it's when you're trading like I'm quite
curious
um before I finish the video I want to
mention that today
is the last day of the campaign that I'm
doing with being EXO uh feel free to
participate it's quite simple it's uh
one of the top exchanges I've been using
for some time that doesn't require kyc
so you can open an account in literally
one minute for that you're gonna get
twenty dollars for free and then if you
deposit fifty dollars and keep it there
for three days at least then you get
under thirty dollars so basically if you
register and you deposit fifty dollars
you get another fifty dollars for free
and then you can also have you know if
you reach uh five thousand dollars in
trading volume including leverage so
it's quite easy you get a hundred
dollars for free and you are also gonna
get ten percent
discount on trading fees and active
Traders using the referral link are
going to get access to the indicator
that I'm working on and probably it's
gonna get ready for next month so if you
are interested in an exchange that
doesn't require kyc or in exchange that
can give you some Rewards or if you want
to also test the indicator then it's the
perfect time and today is the last day
the campaign finishes at midnight UTC
time so you still have you know many
hours left so that's pretty much
everything guys thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you soon